[MUSIC PLAYING]
Ideas are everything.
We're nothing without an idea.
So I go where the ideas lead.
When we get an
idea that we love,
you see it and feel it
and know it all at once.
A desire for an idea is like
putting a little piece of bait
on a hook and lowering
it into the water.
You don't know when
they're going to come
or what will trigger them.
Lo and behold, on a
lucky day, bingo-- you'll
catch an idea, and party time.
If you want to make a feature
length film, all you need to do
is get 70 ideas.
And you write these scenes
on three-by-five cards.
Then when you have 70 of them,
you've got a feature film.
Find your own voice.
Never give up final cut
and total creative freedom.
Everything is connected
in some way or another.
You could be working
on a painting,
and suddenly, something in that
gives you an idea for a film.
Music, painting, cinema--
this is the art life.
In cinema, I don't like rules.
In "Mulholland Drive," we
only had one shot left to get.
WOMAN: How did you get it?
By breaking the rules.
[CHUCKLES] My name
is David Lynch,
and this is my MasterClass.